everything is racist
today on everything is racist Oakland's
woke district attorney Pamela price is
accusing her fellow residents of racism
for expressing outrage about the city's
crime problem
so if you complain about crime you're a
racist
what's that make the victims of crime
super racist it's kind of amazing in
2023 that hating crime is now a hate
crime
meanwhile in Portland Nike is
permanently Closing one of its Flagship
stores due to rampant theft and that's
after Nike offered to pay off duty cops
to provide security which the city
couldn't provide because it didn't have
enough officers on staff so Nike finally
said just screw it
so Tyrus isn't it isn't it racist to
assume that being critical of crime is
being critical of blacks yeah and she
assumes I guess there are no black
victims yeah yeah I'm more upset so when
Nike first came out and I was in college
at the time well it was out for a while
but there was one store we played
Portland State and you didn't even care
about who you were playing yes you were
going to Nike headquarters it was a big
deal and you go in there and you get all
kinds of cool gifts and stuff and now it
had to close down like that is where
we're at it used to be a place where
people would literally take trips to
want to say they walked into the
official Nike store and now that it's
just that's where we're at it's the
drives me crazy and yeah if you say if I
say hey you arresting people for crimes
it's racist I'm assuming that everyone
who's getting arrested is a minority
yeah which makes me racist yeah like
that's
that's the the worst thing you could say
that's like it's like every time
something goes wrong I bet a man did it
yeah you know it's like that that type
of mindset they just say things yeah it
doesn't have to make sense just anything
that's not part of their narrative they
want to get rid of police they want
social workers to come in and help you
so it doesn't matter but until it
happens to her yeah because when it
happens to her then all of a sudden it's
going to be we're the police and we've
got to get these people off the street
and might even use rape racial epitaps
to describe the criminals that robbed
her you know it's interesting I was
thinking about this Riley we and I'm
going to predict this that there will be
a time when people say pressing charges
like let's say you're the victim and
mugged you were mugged somebody's going
to say pressing charges against the
person that mugged you is racist well
think back to that incident I had in San
Francisco yeah where I literally was
ambushed I was mobbed I was held for
ransom for over I mean almost four hours
these protesters held me hostage with
the officers in the room with me the
officers were being held hostage and I'm
looking at the officers you know what is
going on and they told me they couldn't
be seen as anything other than an ally
to that Community they were scared they
were scared to do their own job oh
that's pathetic even the next day the
vice president of student affairs Dr
Jamila Moore right at San Francisco
State University sent an email out to
their student body again keep in mind
they literally demanded that I paid the
money if I wanted to make it home to see
my family safe again I was physically
hit all the things the vice president of
student Affair sent an email out to
their student body saying you know we're
so proud word for word we're so proud of
our brave students we applaud them for
handling Riley Gaines in the manner that
they did
so it is happening
um it's mind-blowing that was my first
kind of like oh my gosh of course you
hear things the justice system is messed
up but I was so appalled and a few weeks
ago I went to Portland Oregon and I have
never in my life seen a city so run down
the rampant I mean people looked like
zombies they were bent over they looked
paralyzed I'm assuming from the drugs
again I'm young here I'm not that
exposed I don't know after the show
[Laughter]
um so yes I think we sir I mean again
think of Thomas we in that situation
where we were victims I wholeheartedly
believe we were victims of sexual
assault by being exposed to a fully
intact naked male where we did not give
consent
um we we are being called bigots we are
being called men yeah all of the things
making us they're trying to deem us as
the oppressors not the oppressed or the
victims cat you're gonna be in Portland
this weekend yeah do you want to borrow
my body armor no I'll be good
um how about my how about my body spray
would you stop asking me that
um so yeah Nike here's the thing so
it turns out that if you want your
business to be open you people have to
like buy the stuff you can't just take
this stuff yes like I don't have an MBA
but I think that a very important part
of any business model is that it has to
be one yeah right so I am doing a show
in Portland on Sunday I'm bringing
Kennedy it's going to be amazing it's
going to be the best time everyone's
gonna have a great time but you do need
a ticket yeah yeah or you can't go can't
come in they can't come in and steal
catches yeah you can't steal me you're
worth more than 900 dollars
real thank you that might be the nicest
thing you've ever said I think that is
it is it'll be edited out yeah
uh lee this is how you this is how you
actually they found a way to end society
that the things you need to preserve
society would be perceived as an
injustice therefore you can no longer
survive as a society
New York is the only state in the entire
country where a judge can't weigh
dangerousness in setting Bell so Eric
Adams
as the mayor of New York City called on
Democrats up in Albany to overhaul
cashless bail to give judges discretion
away dangerousness Danny O'Donnell
Rosie's brother who is an assemblyman in
Manhattan a white liberal Manhattan
Democrat said dangerousness is code for
Black implying that the black mayor was
being racist
when I was campaigning for governor last
year I was advocating for Alvin Bragg to
go I was criticizing his day one memo
where said he was going to refuse to
enforce laws they said that makes me a
racist we should overhaul cashless bail
we should fire Rogue District Attorneys
who refuse to enforce the law you're
saying that as a dog whistle because
you're racist no it's because
law-abiding New Yorkers are fed up that
the streets are being turned over that
we don't have the backs of our men and
women in law enforcement that we are
passing these pro-criminal laws up in
Albany it's on the Merit that we care
about the future of our community our
city our state our country and we're
passionately fighting for it it is
nothing at all to do with the color of
the guy's skin I don't give a crap what
color his skin is what his religion is
whether he's male female trans it
doesn't matter what we care about is
keeping people safe all the left has
left this is calling us a racist
well said
said Lee zeldin hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else